est ce que vous croyez au père noël
moi je croyais jusqu'à l'âge de 4 ans je
me souviens très bien
j'avais 4 et là c'est sur mon lit et je
parlais avec ma grand mère et je lui ai
dit si moi m'a mise au vert noël existe
on attends moi parce que la petite
souris je comprends bien elle a besoin
de temps pour en faire sa maison ont
donc du coup elle vient récupérer nos
dents de lait et comme elle l'était il
met l'argent sous le coussin
donc tout ça c'est très cohérent et lui
le père noël il ya la bise les folies
non parce que je voyais bien pas grand
mais a été en difficulté je continue à
poser des questions vous commencez
acquéreurs sa tournée qui s'y colle à
quelle vitesse
combien d'enfants dans le monde il a
j'ai réalisé et je les dis même mais en
fait le père noël c'est une fête news
quelques années plus tard je suis
étudiant j'ai 21 ans et je me passionne
pour un jeu le backgammon junte aucun
jonas et on joue tous les jours ensemble
et vous savez avec le copain au début on
joue tous faire un jeu sur eux
ça commence à être sérieux lance charrie
ans chose et puis on joue plus au
backgammon
on joue au pad gamme
et quand jour-là gammon un moment donné
je me retrouve en face de lui ai dit tu
sais gérer ni j'ai vu un article est
passé un certain niveau
le backgammon fait que de la chance et
là j'étais hyper déçu parce que moi
j'avais investi mon amie hélène était
dans le fond il avait créé sa propre
fête nous parce que pour moi le gamin
belle vraie stratégie alors j'ai couru
chez lui dans une vidéothèque j'ai
récupéré un bouquin qui parlait de
mathématiques et d'allemand mais je les
lui est en fait non c'est vrai qu'une
partie aléatoire incertaine c'est le jet
de dé ya bien une stratégie et puis la
licence libre à la fin il y avait une
infection qui suggérait nombreux créé un
algorithme qui joue tout seul au diamant
je crois savoir pourquoi c'est parce que
je ne croyais pas ça sera mieux prévient
donc je suis en train de lire mon
bouquin il ya une section à la fin qui
parle de machines langues
le machine learning c'est la possibilité
de créer une intelligence artificielle
qui va réaliser un automate un
algorithme qui joue au ballon et donc je
code et je crée cette intelligence
artificielle mais il ya une
particularité fait que le machine
learning
on n'explique pas toutes les règles
parce que c'est trop compliqué dans le
machine learning on donne que des
exemples j'ai pris des exemples de
partie et je les données à l'algorithme
au bout d'un moment la ligue au rythme a
commencé à comprendre les règles donc je
lui ai proposé de jouer avec lui-même
pour s'améliorer
puis à la fin le backgammon l'algorithme
jouait vraiment contre moi et moi
j'étais hyper fier parce que j'avais été
capable
un instant de transférer non
d'intelligence vers une intelligence
artificielle pour moi c'était la preuve
le dink au backgammon
il y à bien une partie qui n'est pas un
certaine une partie qui est intelligente
puisque un robot était capable
mega man pour moi les mathématiques
c'est comme un certificat anti foutage
de gueule quand j'ai un problème est que
je sais pas si c'est vrai aussi c'est
faux eh ben j'essaie de résoudre cette
question là et du coup j'ai une
meilleure appréciation du vrai du faux
et je me suis aperçu que j'aimais
résoudre ces problèmes quelques années
plus tard je me retrouve à new york et
la rencontre je tombe sur un monsieur
qui en fait est une solide et c'est un
trader très très influent très très
performant et je lui parle je me
souviens de lui il avait un peu le look
du père noël des grands il était gros et
je lui ai dit jim c'est quoi ton métier
là il m'explique il me dit jérémy mon
métier c'est de faire de l'intelligence
artificielle appliquée aux marchés
boursiers au roi du coup j'étais hyper
intrigué parce que je m'intéressais à
l'intelligence artificielle et je vais
demander mais jim à quoi ça sert
d'utiliser l'intelligence artificielle
dans les marchés boursiers alors là il
m'a dit une phrase extraordinaire il m'a
dit jérémy l'intelligence artificielle
c'est la garantie qu'il ne fera plus
jamais aucun krach boursier
du coup je l' ai cru et j'ai bossé d'un
finances et j'ai fait l'intelligence
artificielle appliquée aux marchés
boursiers en 2008 à new york chez lehman
brothers et du coup un moment donné j'ai
senti qu'il y avait un truc un peu
compliqué alors j'ai quitté mon job et
ils ont coulé est ce qu'en réalité ils
ont jamais été capable de se remettre de
mon départ mais pour moi cette histoire
de telli jans artificielle qui serait
capable de garantir le fait qu aurait
plus jamais aucun krach boursier c'est
c'était une fête news mais c'était
c'était une fête nous de trop c'était la
dernière défaite nous c'était impossible
pour moi de supporter un truc pareil
alors je me suis dit désormais en
rentrant en france d'aller créer une
société et sa société leur ait qu'un
seul but c'est d'être capable
d'expliquer à ses clients qu'est ce qui
est vrai qu est ce qui est faux de
discerner le vrai
dufaux et ne plus jamais se faire
manipuler et bien je peux vous assurer
qu'il ya du boulot parce que en
entreprise faire la distinction entre le
vrai et le faux c'est pas facile on en
voit de toutes les couleurs
entre ceux qui sont persuadés que
l'intelligence artificielle va tuer
l'humanité et d'un autre côté ceux qui
sont persuadés que l'intelligence
artificielle fait des miracles
c'est très compliqué de leur dire ça
c'est possible ça c'est pas possible ça
vous l'avez lu mais vous l'avez pas
compris
mais ça c'est vrai on peut le faire tout
de suite et des choses fausses sur
l'intelligence artificielle
on peut en lire partout à hong kong un
cabinet d'avocats a nommé dans son bord
d'un robot fox news
les chercheurs se tue depuis des
dizaines d'années a essayé de donner à
l'intelligence artificielle notion de
sens commun et eux ils prétendent qu'ils
ont donné le sens des affaires
faire impossible en réalité la news et
les vrais c'est qu'ils ont vraiment fait
mais c'est un coup de com le robot
n'existe pas entre elles n'est pas
capable d'avoir une véritable discussion
avec des avocats de comprendre le côté
de non rationnel d'une affaire le
langage cacher qu'on peut avoir parfois
quand on parle d'une affaire qui est
compliqué facebook a créé deux
intelligences artificielles
ces deux intelligences artificielles
ouvertes dans une langue que l'homme ne
comprends pas facebook a décidé de les
éteindre
vous l'avez lu cette news fox news si
vous allez au fond du problème en
réalité c'est vrai que facebook
travaille sur le langage naturel et a
créé justement deux algorithmes qui
était censé converser dans une langue
naturelle pour pouvoir négocier mais ce
qui s'est passé c'est que
l'expérimentation a raté parce qu'à un
moment donné
au lieu de dire qu'ils voulaient
échanger de bananes trois pommes ils ont
commencé à dire banane banane pom pom
pom et du coup sa volée bio lundi à
s'était pas cohérent il voyait bien que
l'expérimentation partait nulle part
alors elles n'ont abandonné mais pendant
un instant on a essayé de vous suggérer
que facebook
était passée à deux doigts d'inventer
une intelligence artificielle qui
avaient comploté contre l'homme et tuer
l'humanité ouf l'on était un temps les
renseignements français travaillent avec
une intelligence artificielle de la msa
bah non ça c'est vrai en fait c'est vrai
et c'est un peu flippant parce que on se
dit quand même il ya peut-être un sujet
de conflit d'intérêts parce que si pour
travailler sur les buts contre l'anti
terrorisme car vrai sujet on est obligé
de passer par des algorithmes qui ne
nous appartiennent pas la commande est
capable de justifier sa auprès des
français c'est leur donner comme on est
capable de protéger leurs données
personnelles
puis un sujet de souveraineté de
dépendance algorithmique
est ce qu'on a vraiment envie de
dépendre de quelqu'un pour notre lutte
antiterroriste est-ce qu'on n'est pas
capables nous même de créer notre propre
intelligent difficiel ça c'est un vrai
sujet les chercheurs ont recréé un
cerveau dans un ordinateur
fox news parce que c'est impossible de
recréer un cerveau à l'identique dans un
ordinateur
en fait ce que dit cet article c'est
quelque chose de beaucoup plus
particulier le cerveau humain il est
fait de réseaux de neurones biologique
des réseaux de neurones c'est ça c'est
un système qui permet de transmettre de
l'information de neurones en neurones
skis ce qui fait que nous on est capable
de discerner de voir de sentir de goûter
d'avoir des émotions
les chercheurs eux ils ont travaillé sur
autre chose ils ont travaillé sur un
réseau de neurones artificiels
ça n'a rien à voir enfin oui il
s'inspire un petit peu c'est un petit
peu comme si on vous disait que les
oiseaux et les avions c'était pareil ça
ne viendrait pas à l'esprit de dire que
des chercheurs ont recréé un oiseau pour
faire new york paris
non ils ont pris l'idée un réseau de
neurones artificiels c ça c'est un
système dans chacune des ronds ça
représente une forme d'information et
chacune d information est transmise
entre les roms qui sont les uns à côté
des autres au début il ya juste les
pixels d'une première photo une photo
d'une voiture et au fur et à mesure par
un système de couches l'intelligence
artificielle va être capable de
comprendre de quelle voiture on parle
la branche aujourd'hui des réseaux de
neurones qui donne le plus de résultats
et qui donne lieu est le plus de
recherches ça s'appelle l'apprentissage
profond le dip le ring dans le dip
learning les réseaux de neurones
artificiels ont la possibilité d'être
organisés en couches se dire que les
tous premiers il voit l'image entier
mais les deuxièmes de son courant de
l'image que par l'intermédiaire de ce
que l'art en dise les premiers et les
derniers eux ne savent que ce qu'on dit
tous les précédents au sujet de l'image
est là où l'intelligence artificielle va
se créer c'est que la première couche
doit être capable de détecter une notion
de bordure de contour de périmètre puis
la deuxième catégorie de coups je vais
être capable de créer une notion de
forme de rond de carrés de surface
et puis la couche la plus noble la plus
élevée est capable de reconnaître des
véritables voitures juste à être capable
de prédire de classifier et de dire
quelle voiture est associé à laquelle
marc voilà ça c'est véritablement ce que
l'intelligence artificielle est capable
de faire aujourd'hui on lui donne une
photo et l'intelligence artificielle va
décrire ce qu'il ya dans la photo une
femme habillée en blanc avec une robe
noire à kate de tennis sur un fond vert
avec deux personnes qui sont derrière
il est vrai ce qui est faux c'est hyper
important
c'est quelque chose de très sérieux
parce que aujourd'hui on a le sentiment
qu'on peut l'entendre beaucoup de choses
sur l'intelligence artificielle mais ces
choses on sait qu'on n'est pas toujours
sûr qu'elles sont vraies alors qu'en
réalité et des choses qui sont très
belles et qui sont déjà réalisés grâce à
l'intelligence artificielle et qui sont
peut-être un peu moins célèbres et ces
choses là que je vais vous raconter
j'ai une amie et médecins alors vous
savez on dit l'intelligence artificielle
va remplacer les médecins
fox news par contre l'intelligence
artificielle va aider les médecins cet
ennemi à la balle +15 parce qu'elle est
à la fois médecin et chercheur en
biologie elle travaille sur un
médicament qui a vocation à donner et à
rendre la fertilité aux femmes qui ont
subi une chimiothérapie
c'est un sujet très sérieux et dans ses
études elle teste les médicaments sur
des souris et pour mesurer l'impact du
médicament elle mesure dans les ovaires
du sourit le nombre de cellules de
follicules est ce que vous savez combien
il ya de ces lille dans des ovaires de
souris est ce que vous savez combien il
ya d'auvers dans une souris enfin vous
servez nord est est ce que vous savez
combien il faut l'étudier de souris pour
être capable de tester le médicament
bien figurez-vous que charlotte elle va
passer 200 jours à ne faire qu
exclusivement compter des follicules de
souris dans des coupes d'auvers pendant
200 jours elle va faire 1 2 3 5
elle va remplir le nombre de follicules
qu'elle a vu dans la première ligne je
vais faire ça sur la deuxième pendant
200 jours alors qu'elle a un bac + 15 et
qu'elle est médecin aurait venu me voir
et m'a dit jérémy j'ai un problème
chouette j'aime bien les problèmes elle
m'a expliqué ce problème de comptage et
je dis ben viens on va bosser ensemble
sur la construction d'une intelligence
artificielle qui va être capable de
compter les cellules au début la
première version était pas top
alors retrouvez pas les mêmes résultats
puis on s'est inspiré du travail que et
charlotte et puis à force de travail
aujourd'hui on a été capable de créer
une intelligence artificielle qui compte
les cellules elle est passée de 200
jours de travail dix minutes le dire
qu'aujourd'hui charlotte elle envisage
de publier son résultat de le communiqué
de les rencontrer des chercheurs d'aller
à des conférences mais encore plus elle
envisage de tester dix autres
médicaments pour aller 10 fois plus vite
dans sa recherche médicale voilà ça
c'est un exemple concret de ce que
l'intelligence artificielle est capable
d'apporter
au médecin ça c'est du vrai on dit
souvent que l'intelligence artificielle
est capable de remplacer les métiers va
créer un jour un robot tueur en
terminator
ah c'est pas pour tout de suite ça c'est
fait que news il n'y a pas de robots
tueurs de robots du juron d'eurobonds
pompiers il ya un an j'ai rencontré le
lieutenant colonel de la brigade des
sapeurs-pompiers de paris
il m'a expliqué qu'il avait un problème
chouette
moi j'aime bien les problèmes il m'a
expliqué que il a un système de camions
mais comme il est dans une situation de
restriction budgétaire il peut pas
mettre 100 % du matériel dans chacun des
camions donc il ya des camions qui ont
tout le matériel et il ya des camions
qui sont un peu un complet ce qui en soi
n'est pas très grave parce que quand il
ya une intervention il envoie toujours
le camion qui est complet mais parfois
il ya des situations il ya plusieurs
interventions et plusieurs urgences au
même moment
il a du coup ça devient dangereux parce
que peut-être qu'il va pas envoyer le
bon matériel sur les bonnes
interventions et qu'il ya des vies qui
sont en jeu
alors on a travaillé ensemble et au bout
de plus ou moins on a été capable de
créer une intelligence artificielle qui
en fonction des informations qu'il a
deux types d'appels le type
d'intervention le type de distance les
mots clés qui sont intervenus il sait à
l'avancé quel type de matériel il est
censé utiliser et comme ça il n'est pas
dans une situation où il peut envoyer un
camion incomplet sur une intervention
qui est très urgente
ça c'est très concret ça ça peut sauver
des vies jean plus chaudement colonel
l'a compris quelque chose
il a compris que les maths c'était un
certificat anti foutage de gueule du
coup il est allé avec notre algorithme
il a expliqué qu'il avait pas assez de
moyens il a eu plus de moyens pour
acheter plus de matériel parce qu'il en
avait la preuve mathématique
on parle aussi de l'intelligence
artificielle qui va créer des cyborgs
avec news il n'y a pas de transe
d'humanisme de mort de la mort des
robots tout ça ça va pas arriver tout de
suite l'homme bionique c'est pas pour
maintenant
par contre il ya des vrais réalisations
concrètes
on travaille depuis un peu plus d'un an
avec
l'équipe de sénologie les hôpitaux de
strasbourg ils sont venus me voir en me
disant qu'il avait un problème
ouais j'aime bien les problèmes
ils m'ont expliqué que après une
opération du sein les femmes qui avaient
donc un cancer du sein ou un risque très
important de contracter un infidèle
moi je savais pas ce que c'était à
l'époque un lymphoedème un peu d'hommes
c'est un épaississement du bras mais
c'est un investissement qui revient
jamais à la normale donc en fait c'est
très inesthétique et dans un cadre de
thérapie globale et du choc lié à la
maladie d'avoir en plus apporter quelque
chose d'inné statique c'est compliqué
pour ces patientes là on a travaillé
avec eux et on a créé un manchon
connecter un manchot c'est comme un
brassard qu'on enfile entre le bras et
qui monte jusqu'à l'épaule
napper ça l'info mais tree hill manche
on y mesure en temps réel
la circonférence du bras en plusieurs
endroits et comme le menton il est
connecté à son téléphone et que sur son
téléphone on peut savoir s'il est en
train de se déplacer c'est un point de
faire du sport c'est un train de faire
autre chose du coup le médecin il est
capable de dire du toit quand tu fais du
tennis à une bonne régulation de la
lymphe donc du coup ça te provoque pas
lymphoedème inversement quand tu fais de
l'ordinateur et tu reste collé à ton
clavier pendant des heures
la lymphe circule mal il ya un risque de
lymphoedème ça c'est du concret ça c'est
du vrai parce que aujourd'hui c'est un
prototype l'ena en cours
d'industrialisation
on va faire valider par des laboratoires
et demain on vendra effectivement des
l'info m qui seront portés par des
personnes qui désormais n'auront plus
problème du côté une esthétique du
lymphoedème voilà ça c'est vrai c'est ce
que l'intelligence artificielle est
capable de faire alors j'ai un dernier
exemple je sais pas si j'ai le temps
pour dernier exemple alors je fais le
dernier exemple j'ai vous savez
aujourd'hui ils mangent l'économique et
hyper important ça s'appelle la qualité
client le service client c'est le fait
qu'on s'assure que vous soyez contents
vous achetez quelque chose aujourd'hui
quand vous achetez sur un site de
e-commerce et que vous tapez quelque
chose dans la fenêtre
ben il ya quelqu'un qui va vous répondre
à quelle heure avec votre colis s'il est
perdu ou est ce qu ils s il
bonne taille s'il en reste ce genre de
choses en réalité ces gens qui vous
répondent ils sont dans un lieu qui
s'appelle un centre de contact client
ils sont tous devant des ordinateurs il
répondra votre chatte pour répondre à
vos questions
les jeunes les clients qui s'appelle
nathaniel et qui venu me voir en disant
qu'il avait un problème
ton problème était un peu particulier
c'est que les gens qui étaient dans son
centre de contacts ils étaient ils
étaient malheureux et en fait il est
dimensionné très vite parce que le
métier hyper inintéressant parce que les
questions sont toujours les mêmes les
réponses sont toujours les même si bien
qu'en fait il t'a pas vraiment en fait
ils ont un dictionnaire de réponse toute
faite ils connaissent par coeur la page
et numéro de la ligne
ils rentrent le numéro est entré et ils
vivent comme ça et on fait leur métier
est tellement inintéressant que les gens
restent pas longtemps et tout une galère
pour lui d'être capable de recruter les
personnes pour faire ce métier là alors
du coup on a travaillé avec lui on s'est
aperçu qu'en réalité il y avait 99 % des
conversations qui était automatisable
sur laquelle on pouvait mettre une
intelligence artificielle mais cette
intelligence artificielle avait la
capacité de comprendre lorsque la
conversation était trop compliquée elle
devait faire appel un humain et du coup
les personnes qui travaillent étaient
beaucoup plus intéressés beaucoup plus
motivés et ça ça fait monter en flèche
le chiffre d'affaires de ce client là ça
c'est une vraie réalisation
d'intelligence artificielle c'est
vraiment du concret alors vous allez me
dire c'est vraiment du concret mais il
ya aussi un enjeu un peu éthique
sociétal parce que ces gens là
finalement ils vont peut-être perdre
leur job et l'intelligence artificielle
c'est vrai en partie participe à
détruire des jobs et ce qui est vraiment
très important c'est que pour être sûr
de savoir si on fait des bons choix au
des mauvais choix avec l'intelligence
artificielle c'est le plus important
c'est de distinguer le vrai du faux
parce que en dise qu'un blanc le vrai du
faux
vous êtes sûr que vous ferez jamais
manipulé vous êtes sûr que vous ne
croirai plus jamais à défectueuse en
réfléchissant par vous même en faisant
preuve d'esprit critique
en apprenant par vous même vous êtes
dans une situation vous allez pouvoir
participer à décider quel est le choix
de vie
que notre société va avoir avec
l'avènement de l'intelligence
artificielle parce que ça c'est sûr
l'intelligence artificielle va arriver
et quand elle va arriver vaut mieux
savoir comment veulent employer plutôt
que d'être obligé d'être manipulés par
des gens qui seraient mal intentionnés
alors je repense à cette discussion que
j'ai eue avec ma grand-mère quand
j'avais quatre ans quand je lui disais
que je croyais pas au père noël et
aujourd'hui j'y réfléchis et je me dis
une intelligence artificielle qui vous
livre en 24 heures en bas de chez vous
il connaît l'historique de tous vos
achats qui sait que si vous avez aimé
tel produit vous aimerez tel produit il
est capable de livrer toute la france
tous les enfants en france en moins de
24 heures le soir du 24 novembre le 24
décembre
existe en fait comme quoi vous voyez
c'est extrêmement difficile être sûr
qu'on peut distinguer le vrai du faux
merci
[Applaudissements]